[Musique]
toute qualité sentiment y arrive comme
par les mains gros leur dire
[Musique]
un petit peu de temps en pleine
répétition ou un conseil arrive comment
on sent à où aujourd'hui mais ça au
moins pressé mais il a hâte d'être le 25
mars et partager un gaillard soirée
ensemble un concert est important pour
parce que pour la première fois où ça
propose ou de bonnes compositions
l'important pour ça mais très important
il pense que c'est un façon exprime à
moi et façon on dit qui s'amélie ou sa
me saute et que ça me fait surtout
et la musique ou la tombe dedans depuis
tanti
mon papa et nous Hangouts
les premiers fois où ça la trappe à ou
quoi m'a toujours été dedans avec papa
il y a toujours à la main partout dans
le cabas dans sa vie même ici comme un
effet bonne répétition tu es toujours
dans son pacte
[Musique]
elle m'a toujours m'a toujours aimé ça
moi je vais me la musique collectif
[Musique]
il était descendent par volailles il me
te refait pareil il me dit quoi
en dehors d'autres papa bon peu Daniel
Waro alpin
là en fait heureusement balatella pour
faire passer un nouveau message donne à
nous cinq menena pour prendre et
continuer là dedans
et on reste là à New York est-ce normal
[Musique]
que ça il manque à toute bonne jeune
pour que cette propriété se maloya à
notre culture ami
voudrais bien intervenir de bonne école
à mont-de-marma
il reste la musique dehors et il oublie
ça nous sorte que ça nous les comment on
peut décrire une musique aujourd'hui
comme ça où il y aime jouer alors c'est
maloya mais il va dit plutôt maloya
fusion parce que Nena guitare basse
batterie Cora la bonpeuse instruments
ils sortent dehors et c'est ça qui fait
ce
[Musique]
d'un joli projet là en préparation un EP
à venir cette année et Cousteau sa
proposait là-dedans pour moi c'est écrit
sur la vie chaque nuit ressens sur le
moment je fais pas ce
sentiment de Moon fait mon Banat que moi
les enfants mais que mes gains sont
aussi qui moi les filles d'être
réunionnaise aussi dans mon long cosy et
dans notre musicalité
[Musique]
l'important pour de mettre en avant le
créole très important toute mon texte
est écrit en créole
[Musique]